have people come up to you and like
talked about the show oh I've had so
many experiences with people and one of
my wildest ones which I shared with
everybody on our group chat I'm walking
out of the gym one morning and uh this
woman walks past me and then she grabs
my arm as I continued to walk she said
wait a minute are you in fellow
Travelers and I was like yes why are you
holding on to me she starts breaking
down the tears instantly because she
said my dad is a hawk oh wow and he was
married to my mother and they recently
got divorced and he came out as gay and
I have not been able to process this
properly and because of your show I'm
able to understand what my dad went
through the choices he made and why he
is the way he is today and I'm learning
to love him even closer that's beautiful
beautiful I
mean you can't get more um that is the
purpose of why we do what we do as
actors um to kind of hold this mirror up
to society being like I see you you are
seen um and the fact that she's able to
establish a stronger relationship with
her dad is really powerful these are the
stories of people Untold the people who
are considered other the people who are
considered uh um to some gross um to
some U not worthy of their entire human
existence and we get to honor them
through fellow Travelers and show them
in the most beautiful light in the most
handsome light in the most proud light
um and in the most um ability to love
yourself and stand up for yourself and
say enough is enough um I think that the
world needs to uh see this project to
understand that there's so many other
stories just like the people in this
show um that deserve to be told and
deserve to be validated I agree well I
just have to say as somebody you know
who really connected with the show there
was such dignity in everybody's
storyline and I felt like even though
we're talking about people who were in
the shadows for so long it was told in a
way that was so Universal Dre you
touched on it no matter who you are
where you come from when you watch the
show you can understand people wanting
to love and feel love and that sort of
Simplicity is so beautiful and I just
wanted to thank each of you for your
hand in that because it was a story that
hasn't been told thank youan Alex and
Jani and Noah the finale the ever
incredible finale of fellow Travelers
airs this Friday December 15th on
Showtime and Paramount plus we'll be
right
[Music]
back
you